twisted priorities that's the focus of
tonight's angle
you can tell a lot about a person but by
what he or she prioritizes in life so
your kids are in a soccer tournament do
you cancel that golf outing happening
the same day or not
and same with politicians and activists
when the you know what is hitting the
fan in the country do you jump in to
solve the problem or do you blow it off
and work on pet projects that don't help
solve anything
well that's what's happening right now
here in the united states
we just learned that retail sales are
falling as inflation robs americans of
their spending money extra spending
money if they had any
today's rate hike by the fed was the
highest since 94. that's going to smash
the housing market
and the rate hike too little too late as
peter schiff said last night
and sure enough we knew this was going
to happen home builder sentiment dropped
to its lowest level in two years that
was during the pandemic
and then the producer price index which
measures wholesale prices rose in may by
nine no 0.9 which is double the april
increase
so democrats answer to all this
just meaningless
in order to appear as though they're
doing something the byte administration
is bad-mouthing the very industry his
administration decided to go to war with
in a time of global crisis oil companies
should be doing everything they can to
expand capacity and lower cost at the
pump instead they are charging record
profits at the expense of american
families president biden is putting a
spotlight on this and calling on oil
refiners to invest those records those
record profits to increase capacity
reading with kjp
well all i can say to that is those darn
capitalists
now biden's letter he sent this letter
out and ordered the oil producers to
produce more oil
basically for less money oh that's
realistic
he put the brakes on oil production he
destroyed our energy independence then
he rails against the oil and gas
industry for not producing more oil
when the democrats aren't throwing sand
in the fan and the actual policy making
side of things they and their supporters
keep busy pursuing a totally idiotic
woke agenda
so when you spend 120 bucks as i did
today to fill my tank well are you going
to be relieved to know that there will
be more general neutral bathrooms on
capitol hill
yeah
and laser focused on supply chain
problems the president will also expand
access to sex change procedures and
puberty blockers nationwide
all right and with everything going
south fast they had to pause everything
to celebrate the democrats holiest month
of the year
pride is back at the white house
from day one
from day one this has been the most
pro-equality administration in history
led by guys like pete button
i think we have more lgbtq plus people
than any administration or every
administration combined
well that'll lower the price at the pump
great
and if you're worried about china and
you think our foreign policy is in
tatters the state department's answer to
that will surely scare xi jinping
hello twitter world
i'm ambassador gina abercrombie when
stanley the u.s department of state's
first chief diversity and inclusion
officer i'm delighted to welcome you to
the state department's newest twitter
account at state department d-e-i-a
how exciting
and meanwhile on the hill democrats are
so desperate to hold on to power they're
trying to scare you away from voting
republican because guess what
all those minorities running and winning
well they're actually closet racists who
have the i word on their mind
it would um impeach president biden as
quickly as possible it would also
embolden
republicans and the far right and white
nationalists across the country to begin
to believe that it is their time this is
a group that has been radicalized by the
great replacement myth and many other
things and have been pushing for
violence and pushing for even civil war
thank god new yorkers have a man of his
searing intellect representing the
people in these troubled economic times
but congressman bowman is just taking a
lesson as an a from the highest paid
racial huckster around
the intellectual force after all behind
the democrats embrace of the systemic
racism myth a man whose sole
goal is to cash in on poorly written
books for adults and kids
the plot's always the same
america is a rotten hateful place with
an awful history and everything and
everyone is racist
by three years old our kids have an
adult-like concept of race by three
years old our kids are attaching
qualities like smartness and honesty and
cleanliness
to skin color and all the while parents
are are thinking and teachers that
our kids aren't thinking about skin
color or even seeing it and so we're not
stepping in to counteract those messages
and we need to
so democrats in the media actually think
that americans who are freaking out now
about their monthly budgets being
overrun
actually that they want to marinate in
that stuff
people can raise racist ideas and not
even know that they're doing it
i think that's very important to make
that a point to make the unfortunate
truth is we live in a society of all
sorts of racial inequities and
disparities all sorts of ideas
attaching goodness or badness to
particular skin colors we have to be
teaching our children a different way of
thinking a way of being you know in the
world
at a time in the country badly needs
optimism and sound ideas
liberals keep returning to the same
poisoned well
it's all a distraction and it's always
negative
what about children that have been
raised over the past four five six years
one of the kids first memories of
charlottesville
january the 6th a proud boy
i just do wonder what sort of negative
impact that's going to have on so many
young kids coming of age
really joe because i think the better
question is
is the one that you should be discussing
what sort of negative impact will an
economic crash and increase drug abuse
after two years of covert restrictions
have on our young kids
but that of course asking that question
confronting it that would put democrats
under the microscope which they don't
have the guts to do
the sad truth is that the democrats have
been out of steam for years
they're not interested in raising your
standard of living or keeping the
streets safer or making sure the public
schools are competitive with their
global counterparts i understand any of
that
all they're capable of is decline
division and hate
just look at the freak still showing up
at the homes of supreme court justices
look at the attacks on crisis pregnancy
centers and the relative silence from
elected officials
left-wing criminals have the tacit
approval of the party
of democrat party that's currently on
life support
these are people with twisted priorities
and no real plans to help the country
they're going to pretend of course
they're hard at work on things like
fighting climate change or fighting
institutional racism or corporate greed
but in the end it's all just a pathetic
power grab
but in less than five months the voters
will be doing a power grab of their own
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else